Hey there Shankar here. A few weeks ago we were finishing up an episode called In the Heat of the Moment. It's about hot and cold emotional states and how certain situations can cause us to become strangers to ourselves. If you haven't heard it yet, check it out. We're really proud of it. Working on it also got us thinking about another episode we did a few years ago. It's about teenagers in Chicago and a program that tries to keep kids from acting in anger, from making mistakes that could affect the course of their lives. In other words, it's trying to help kids pull back from the brink when they're in a hot state. We thought that episode was worth another listen, so we're bringing it to you today. Hope you enjoy it.
大家好，我是香卡。几周前，我们制作完了一期名为《当头棒喝》的节目。它探讨的是人们处于激动或冷静的情绪状态时，某些特定情境如何让我们变得连自己都不认识了。如果你还没听过，不妨去听听看。我们为这期节目感到非常骄傲。制作这期节目的同时也让我们想起了几年前做过的另一期节目。那是关于芝加哥的青少年，以及一个试图阻止孩子们冲动行事、避免他们做出可能影响一生命运的错误的项目的。换句话说，它试图帮助孩子们在情绪激动时悬崖勒马。我们觉得那期节目值得再次聆听，所以今天我们把它带给大家。希望你们会喜欢。
The fight was over a pair of gym shoes. At night, on the south side of Chicago, and this is what came of it. One teenager faces years in prison. Another, a boy of just 15, is dead. The incident might not have even made the news, except the victim was the grandson of a long-serving congressman. At a press conference, that congressman, Danny Davis, did something unusual. He grieved, not just for his own grandson, but for his grandson's killer. I grieved for my family. I grieve for the young man who pulled the trigger. I grieve for his family, his parents, his friends, some of whom will never see him again. It is so unfortunate when these tragedies continue to occur and re-occur, and
这场争斗起因于一双运动鞋。在一个夜晚的芝加哥南区，这就是它带来的结果。一名青少年面临着多年的监禁。另一个年仅15岁的男孩则失去了生命。这起事件甚至可能都不会登上新闻，如果受害者不是一位资深国会议员的孙子的话。在一次新闻发布会上，那位国会议员丹尼·戴维斯做了一件不同寻常的事。他不仅为自己的孙子感到悲痛，也为杀死他孙子的凶手感到悲痛。我为我的家人感到悲痛。我也为那个扣动扳机的小伙子感到悲痛。我为他的家人、他的父母、他的朋友感到悲痛，其中有些人将永远再也见不到他了。每当这些悲剧不断发生、再次发生时，真的是极其不幸，
somehow or another, our society has not been able to find and exact the answers and solutions. The solutions we do have often produce more disputes than results. Conservatives call for harsher sentencing and better policing. Liberals want gun control and more social service programs. One thing's clear, even as we argue, people are dying. So what can be done? One community group has an unusual idea. It believes that perhaps violence can be stopped
不知何故，我们的社会一直没能找到并开出确切的答案和解决方案。我们现有的解决方案往往带来的争端多于结果。保守派呼吁实行更严厉的刑罚和更好的警务管理。自由派则想要枪支管制和更多的社会服务项目。有一点很明确，即便在我们争论不休的时候，人们仍在死去。那么能做些什么呢？有一个社区团体有一个不寻常的想法。它相信，或许暴力可以通过
with a breath of few moments and a tiny tweak to the way we think. Very, very often, you know, if they could only take back five minutes of their life, a lot of these kids, a lot of the people that are locked up would have a very different life. Thinking our way out of crime, this week on Hidden Brain. Our story begins with another death on the south side of Chicago. One night in the fall of 2007, Amadou Sis, a young PhD student from Senegal, was walking home after a gathering on the University of Chicago campus.
深呼吸几次以及对我们的思维方式做出一点微调来加以阻止。非常非常经常地，你知道的，如果他们能够挽回生命中的五分钟，很多这样的孩子，很多被关起来的人，将会拥有截然不同的人生。本周的《隐藏的大脑》带你探讨用理性思维摆脱犯罪。我们的故事从芝加哥南区发生的另一起命案开始。2007年秋天的一个晚上，来自塞内加尔的年轻博士生阿马杜·西斯在芝加哥大学校园的一次聚会后步行回家。
He was confronted by a stranger, 17-year-old Demetrius Warren. Warren stuck a stolen 22 caliber handgun in CISIS chest and tried to take his water bottle and backpack. And I don't think anyone knows exactly what happened. Maybe Amadoucis didn't let go of his backpack or his water bottle quite quickly enough, and then Demetrius Warren pulled the trigger and shot him basically at point blank range in the chest and killed him. This is Jens Ludwig. He's an economist at the University of Chicago, focusing on social policy and crime.
他遭到了一名陌生人的拦截，这名陌生人是17岁的德米特里·沃伦。沃伦将一把偷来的.22口径手枪顶在西斯的胸口，并试图抢走他的水壶和背包。我想没有人确切知道当时发生了什么。也许阿马杜·西斯没有及时松开他的背包或水壶，然后德米特里·沃伦就扣动了扳机，基本上是在近距离朝他的胸口开枪并杀害了他。这位是延斯·勒德威格。他是芝加哥大学的一位经济学家，专注于社会政策和犯罪研究。
He says the murder of Amidu sis was a very definition of senseless. If they thought about it for even one second, it is very hard to imagine that anyone would think that it was a good idea to shoot someone at point blank range in exchange for a book bag and a water bottle that would surely have a resale value of not more than a couple bucks at best. If they thought about it for even one second. It turns
他说，杀死阿马杜·西斯的行为完全可以称之为无意义的代名词。如果他们哪怕思考了一秒钟，都很难想象会有人觉得在近距离开枪杀人以换取一个背包和一个水壶是个好主意，这个背包和水壶转售的价值充其量也绝对超不过几块钱。如果他们哪怕思考了一秒钟的话。结果
out many murders in Chicago occur because someone didn't stop for that one second. We went to the medical examiner's office and we just reviewed quite a number of case files in which young men had been murdered. Harold Pollack is a public health researcher who works with the end of the University of Chicago Crime Lab. Not long after the killing of Amidu Siss, Harold decided to figure out what was behind the many homicides in the city. And so many of these incidents, you just read the story, you know, medical examiners report is typically, you know, pretty brief, you know, there would be, you would get a lot of details about what happened
证明，芝加哥的许多谋杀案之所以发生，就是因为有人没有停顿那一秒钟。我们去了法医办公室，查阅了相当多的年轻男子被谋杀的案卷。哈罗德·波拉克是一名公共卫生研究员，他在芝加哥大学犯罪实验室工作。在阿马杜·西斯遇害后不久，哈罗德决定弄清楚该市众多凶杀案背后的原因。在这么多这样的事件中，你读到这个故事时，你知道的，法医报告通常来说相当简短，你知道的，你会得到很多关于
to the physical body, but usually there would be a two paragraph report about what happened. And many of these cases, you would just read it and say, wow, I just can't believe that someone ended up dead. And there was nothing at stake here that was anywhere near the stakes of a human life. When most people might imagine that killings occur because of a gang hit or cold blooded revenge or premeditated murder, the records reveal the laundry lists of slights.
身体受到了什么伤害的细节，但通常会有一段两段左右的报告讲述事情是如何发生的。在许多这样的案子里，你读完只会说，哇，我简直不敢相信有人居然因此丧命。而这里面涉及的利益根本无法与一条人命相提并论。当大多数人想象凶杀案是因为黑帮火拼、冷血复仇或蓄意谋杀而发生时，记录却揭示了一连串微不足道的轻慢。
Someone stepped on someone else's shoe or stole a coat or lobbed an insult. And from that tiny spark, things escalated into violence and murder. spark, things escalated into violence and murder. Harold is interviewed incarcerated young men who tell him that regret comes almost as fast as anger. The kid who committed the homicide, five minutes later, himself, he's thinking about, wow, this was over a jacket, you know, very, very often, very often, if they could only take back, five minutes of their life, a lot of these kids, a lot of the people that are locked up would have a very different life.
有人踩了别人的鞋子，或者偷了一件外套，或者说了一句侮辱的话。而从这个微小的火星开始，事情升级成了暴力和谋杀。火星，事情升级成了暴力和谋杀。哈罗德采访过被收监的年轻人，他们告诉他，后悔的情绪几乎和愤怒一样快地涌现。那个犯下凶杀案的孩子，五分钟后，他自己就在想，哇，这居然是因为一件夹克，你知道的，非常非常频繁地，很多时候，如果他们能够挽回生命中的五分钟，很多这样的孩子，很多被关起来的人，将会拥有截然不同的人生。
As Jens and Harold puzzled over how minor incidents could spiral out of control, they realized they were asking a question that was fundamentally psychological. Why do people do irrational things? Why do people act so unthinkingly? And then they had a flash of insight. Teenage boys on the south and west sides of Chicago are not the only ones who act without thinking.
正当延斯和哈罗德百思不得其解，为什么小小的摩擦会失控演变成大祸时，他们意识到自己正在探讨一个根本上属于心理学的问题。为什么人们会做出不理智的事？为什么人们的行事会如此不经大脑？接着，他们灵光一现。芝加哥南区和西区的男青少年并不是唯一不经大脑行事的人。
We all do it. Psychologists even have a term for this behavior. Automaticity. A lot of our thinking that we do in life is very scripted and is very automatic. And we couldn't go through life if we didn't have very quick reactions to things that we don't give a lot of thought to, partly because it just takes too much time. If someone gets in my face right away and there's an immediate threat to my safety, I have to respond automatically if I sort of stop and conduct a little mental onj trial
我们所有人都会这样。心理学家甚至为这种行为起了一个术语。自动化反应。我们在生活中进行的很多思考都非常模式化、非常自动化。如果我们对事物没有无需过多思考的快速反应，我们就无法在这个社会生存下去，部分原因正是因为那样会花费太多时间。如果有人当面挑衅我，并且对我的安全构成了直接威胁，我就必须做出自动化的反应，如果我还要停下来进行一个小型的精神法庭审判
before I respond, that's not gonna be very functional for me. In other words, we often act almost unconsciously. A door is in front of us and we open it. We don't think, how do I open this door? We just do it. If someone hits us, we might also, just as fast, hit back. How old are members of an incident that occurred to him. He was in a burger king, and someone else in line shoved him.
再做出反应，那对我来说就一点也不实用了。换句话说，我们经常几乎是在无意识的情况下行动。一扇门在我们面前，我们就把它打开。我们不会去想，我该怎么开这扇门？我们直接就去开了。如果有人打我们，我们可能也会同样迅速地反击。哈罗德回忆起他经历过的一件小事。他在汉堡王排队时，队伍里的另一个人推了他一下。
Harold's not a fighter, but for a moment, he felt a primal urge to lash out. And I felt that burning sensation, and then I kind of reminded myself that I'm a nerdy middle aged professor, and I should just throw my tray away and move on. But it was, you know, I thought about it. And I think if I were, if the 17-year-old me
哈罗德不是个好斗的人，但在那一刻，他感到了反击的原始冲动。我感到了那种灼热感，然后我提醒自己，我是一个书呆子似的中年教授，我应该把托盘扔掉然后走开。但确实，你知道的，我想过。而且我想如果我是，如果17岁的我
might well have ended up, you know, with the gash in his head. How did it get into a fight? Because before he acted, he thought for one second about the situation and the consequences. Could it be Harold and Jens wondered that this simple step, think before you act, could be a solution to violent crime in Chicago? A lot of the violence problem, at least this was our hypothesis doing the study. A lot of the violence problem on the streets of Chicago is not necessarily driven by bad people. It results from bad decisions that people make in the moment.
很可能最后会落得个头上挂彩的下场。怎么会卷入斗殴呢？因为在他采取行动之前，他对当时的情况和后果思考了一秒钟。哈罗德和延斯不禁思索，这简单的一步——三思而后行，会不会就是解决芝加哥暴力犯罪的良方呢？暴力问题很大一部分，至少这是我们做研究时的假设。芝加哥街头的很多暴力问题不一定是由坏人引起的。它是由人们在当时情境下做出的糟糕决定导致的。
And our hypothesis was if we could identify some promising intervention that could help people avoid some of these common kind of judgment and decision-making errors that that might be helpful in producing the violence problem. Researchers have spent years studying ways to get people to behave less automatically, to change the scripts in their head. One technique that's often used is called CBT, cognitive behavioral therapy. The idea is to develop new scripts and new habits to address problems. An alcoholic, for example, might need to practice taking a different route home from work,
我们的假设是，如果我们能够找到某种有前景的干预措施，帮助人们避免一些常见的判断和决策失误，那可能会对解决暴力问题有所帮助。研究人员花了多年时间研究如何让人减少自动化行为，改变他们脑海中的思维模式。一种经常使用的技术被称为CBT，即认知行为疗法。这个想法是开发新的模式和新的习惯来解决问题。例如，一个酗酒者可能需要练习选择一条不同的路线下班回家，
a route that doesn't go by their favorite bar. Someone with anger problems might need to practice counting to 10 before responding. A person prone to depression might need to talk to themselves about how feelings of sadness can be transient. Changing the way we behave can change the way we think, and changing the way we think can change our lives. Mostly, this kind of therapy takes place one-on-one with a trained expert. How do you do this on a large scale with thousands of kids from some of the poorest and most
一条不经过他最喜欢的酒吧的路。有愤怒管理问题的人可能需要练习在回应前数到10。有抑郁倾向的人可能需要说服自己，悲伤的情绪是如何短暂的。改变我们的行为方式可以改变我们的思维方式，而改变我们的思维方式可以改变我们的人生。通常，这种治疗是在训练有素的专家的指导下一对一进行的。你如何对芝加哥一些最贫困和最暴力社区的成千上万个孩子大规模地开展这种治疗呢？你不可能把他们全部找来做一对一的心理治疗。
violent neighborhoods in Chicago? You can't bring them all in for one-on-one psychotherapy. As it turned out, Yens and Harold found a local group called Youth Guidance that was already trying something similar. It was offering kids a kind of low-budget psychotherapy within their neighborhood schools. There was nothing fancy about the program. Kids checked in with counselors regularly, talked about issues, tried to develop new habits. Jens and Harold wanted to find out if this low-budget effort
事实证明，延斯和哈罗德找到了一家名为“青年指导”的当地组织，该组织已经在尝试类似的事情了。它在社区学校里为孩子们提供一种低成本的心理治疗。这个项目没有什么花哨的地方。孩子们定期与辅导员交流、讨论问题、尝试培养新习惯。延斯和哈罗德想弄清楚这种低成本的努力
might be effective on a mass scale in combating crime. They wanted to test the program rigorously. They wanted to conduct a randomized controlled study the same way it's done in medicine. They didn't want to be misled by their hopes and intuitions. We basically have a bunch of well-intentioned city and state governments and a bunch of well-intentioned NGOs out there, innovating and trying lots and lots of different things over time, but not doing that in a way where we can actually
是否能在大规模打击犯罪方面奏效。他们想要严格地检验这个项目。他们希望像医学研究那样，进行一项随机对照研究。他们不想被自己的希望和直觉所误导。我们基本上有一群出于好意的市级和州级政府，以及一群出于好意的非政府组织，随着时间的推移，他们在不断创新，尝试非常非常多的不同事情，但并没有以一种能够让我们真正
rigorously study and evaluate which things are working and without good feedback about which of our innovations are actually helpful. It's very hard to move in the right direction. Performing a randomized controlled study in the real world is very difficult, but Harold and Yens teamed up with Youth Guidance to study the program. Now, the specific program is called BAM, short for Becoming a Man. The researchers compiled a list of young men living in some of the most dangerous parts of Chicago. They were thousands of teenagers to choose from.
严格研究和评估哪些事情正在起作用的方式去做，并且在缺乏关于我们的哪些创新真正有帮助的良好反馈的情况下，我们很难朝着正确的方向前进。在现实世界中进行随机对照研究非常困难，但哈罗德和延斯与“青年指导”组织合作来研究这个项目。现在，这个特定的项目被称为BAM，即“成为一个男人”的缩写。研究人员编制了一份居住在芝加哥最危险地区的年轻男子的名单。有成千上万的青少年可供挑选。
We basically flipped the coin to decide which of the kids would get offered the program and which wouldn't. Before I tell you what they found, I want to take you into the program so you can see how it works. Bam brings together young men who are barely scraping by, most have a de-average. Nearly 40% have been arrested. Their chances of dropping out of school and ending up in prison are extremely high and they live in neighborhoods like West Garfield Park. It has one of the highest rates of violent crime in Chicago. This is the home of the BAM program at Orr High School. Stay with us.
我们基本上是通过抛硬币来决定哪些孩子能获得这个项目，哪些不能。在我告诉你他们的发现之前，我想带你深入了解这个项目，这样你就能看到它是如何运作的。“BAM”将那些勉强度日、大部分人成绩低于平均水平的年轻男子聚集在一起。近40%的人曾被捕过。他们辍学并最终入狱的几率极高，而且他们住在像西加菲尔德公园这样的社区。这里是芝加哥暴力犯罪率最高的地区之一。这里是奥尔高中的“BAM”项目所在地。请继续收听。
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Or high school feels like a place that was built on big dreams. It was designed in the early 1970s by the firm of the legendary architect, Mies Wanderow. It's huge, but interconnecting clusters were supposed to make it less overwhelming for the 2000 students expected to attend. Maybe it worked at first, but that dream school no longer exists. Or it's now struggling. Vast sections sit empty. Enrollment is dwindled as kids flee to charter schools. The empty hallways echo. A police cruiser idles outside. Kids walk through a metal detector to enter school.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。奥尔高中给人的感觉像是一个建立在伟大梦想之上的地方。它是由传奇建筑师密斯·凡德罗的公司在20世纪70年代初设计的。它非常宏大，但相互连接的建筑群原本是为了让预计到校的2000名学生不会感到过于压抑。也许一开始管用，但那个梦想中的学校已经不复存在了。奥尔高中现在正苦苦挣扎。大片区域闲置着。随着孩子们逃向特许学校，招生人数不断减少。空荡荡的走廊里回荡着回音。一辆警车在外面空转。孩子们通过金属探测器进入学校。
In one classroom, Larry Parts, a BAM counselor, waits for students to arrive. Larry thinks of his job as a calling. I'm bored into this. I mean, I've been in this community for 45 years. I used to be a police officer in this community. And there's nothing for me to gain, but to help reach every kid. Larry says part of what motivates him now
在一间教室里，BAM的辅导员拉里·帕茨正等待着学生的到来。拉里把他的工作看作是一种天职。我对此深有感触。我的意思是，我在这个社区呆了45年了。我以前是这个社区的警察。我这么做没有任何个人利益可图，唯一的目的就是去帮助触及每一个孩子。拉里说，现在激励他的一部分原因
is what he saw as a cop when he could look into the lives of the people around him. It saw a lot of mental illness in the families. When you would make domestic calls, you would see mental illnesses in the homes. You would see a lot of addictions. You would see people going to jail and being torn apart without having a mother and father. You would see a lot of poverty. People not having jobs, not having skills,
是他当警察时所看到的景象，当时他能够窥视周围人们的生活。他在家庭中看到了很多心理疾病。当你接到家庭纠纷出警电话时，你会看到家庭中的心理疾病。你会看到很多瘾君子。你会看到人们进监狱，家庭支离破碎，没有母亲和父亲。你会看到很多贫穷。人们没有工作，没有技能，
not having, not being able to work and take care of their families. But one of the worst things that I've seen is that when people do make mistakes, there's no way to rewrite that mistake. So that's what Larry's doing now, trying to keep kids from making those mistakes, they won't be able to correct. Each week, 11 young men come in for a counseling session that he helps to lead. Shortly after noon, the young men file in, and then it's time for a check-it. The sessions always begin with this check-in, a brief summary of what's going on in everyone's
无法工作来照顾他们的家人。但我见过最糟糕的事情之一是，当人们犯下错误时，根本没有办法去改写这个错误。所以这就是拉里现在正在做的事，努力防止孩子们犯下那些他们无法纠正的错误。每周，有11名年轻男子来参加他协助主持的辅导课。中午过后不久，这些年轻人鱼贯而入，接着就到了签到时间。课程总是从这个签到环节开始，简要总结每个人
life. People have to talk about how they feel physically, intellectually, emotionally, and spiritually. The young men give raw and honest answers. My name is Chavante, and I'm checking in physically. I'm feeling good. All right, I'm checking in. My name is James. Physically, physically, I'm tired.
生活中的近况。大家必须谈谈自己在身体、理智、情感和精神上的感受。年轻人们给出了真诚而坦率的回答。我叫查万特，我从身体状况开始签到。我感觉很好。好的，我来签到。我名字叫詹姆斯。身体上，身体上，我很累。
I didn't get that much sleep last night carrying boxes all night. It's election, I've been thinking about this math test on Friday. I've been studying hard to push my seat up to a B and eat it better than to A, because I know Ducca will bring my grade up a lot. The check-in takes a lot of time and I find myself glancing at my watch. But then I realize these are kids without a lot of emotional support in their lives. Larry says they need space to talk, to be heard, and most of all, to feel they're not alone. That someone is listening. Someone has their back.
我昨晚没睡好，整晚都在搬箱子。这是选举，我一直在想星期五的数学考试。我一直在努力学习，想把我的分数从C推到B，然后争取比A更好，因为我知道D-U-C-C-A会把我的成绩拉高很多。签到花了很多时间，我发现自己忍不住看了看手表。但随后我意识到，这些孩子在生活中并没有得到太多的情感支持。拉里说，他们需要空间去倾诉、去被倾听，最重要的是，去感受到他们并不孤单。有人在倾听他们。有人在背后支持他们。
That's one of the things that we really value here in our groups. It's again the trust of people. Teachers come to the school all the time. Principal's come to the school all the time and they're gone. And the the time, and they're gone. And the kids know this, and they have no one they can depend on every day. After the check-in, the young men usually tell stories, role play, and then do various exercises. On this day, they do a trust walk, where one student closes his eyes and is let around various obstacles in the classroom by a partner. Hold on, we're gonna wait. We got a little bit of traffic ahead of us.
这是我们在小组中非常珍视的事情之一。这同样也是人与人之间的信任。老师们一直都在来学校。校长们也一直都在来学校，但他们转眼就走了。而且孩子们心里清楚这一点，他们没有一个每天都能依靠的人。签到结束后，年轻人通常会讲故事、进行角色扮演，然后做各种练习。这一天，他们做了一个信任行走练习，其中一个学生闭上眼睛，由一个同伴引领着绕过教室里的各种障碍物。等等，我们要等一下。我们前面有点交通堵塞。
Okay, we're gonna turn this way. I noticed something as the students are walking around the classroom. The young men who have their eyes closed start out looking tense. But then they relax. All they have to do is focus on what their friend is telling them. Go here, go here, go here. Their partners, meanwhile, focus on what their friend is telling them. Go here, go here, go here. Their partners meanwhile, focus on protecting them.
好的，我们要往这边转。我注意到当学生们在教室里走动时发生了一些变化。那些闭上眼睛的学生一开始看起来很紧张。但随后他们放松了。他们只需要专注于朋友对他们说的话。去这儿，去这儿，去这儿。与此同时，他们的同伴则专注于保护他们。
For a brief moment, they're not looking out for themselves, but for someone else. It's a forced kind of intimacy, but very quickly, it becomes real. When it's over, there's a real happiness in the air and a sense of pride. It's so good, I was born doing it, but see, I visualized the room before I did it. So I already knew what I was at. I felt the sunlight on my ass. So I knew I was bad in winter.
在短暂的一刻里，他们关心的不是自己，而是别人。这是一种被迫产生亲密感的方式，但很快，它就变得真实起来。当练习结束时，空气中弥漫着真正的快乐和一种自豪感。太棒了，我生来就会这个，但我做之前在脑海中把房间可视化了。所以我已经知道我在哪了。我感觉到了屁股上的阳光。所以我知道我在冬天。
I smelled the pizza. I knew I was over here. Another bad exercise is the fifth. Students again are divided into pairs. One of them is given a ball. The other is told he has 30 seconds to go get the fifth. Students again are divided into pairs. One of them is given a ball. The other is told he has 30 seconds to go get the ball. Almost always the second student tries to wrestle the ball away. When times up a counselor asks, did you ever consider they might have been an easier way? What about just asking for the ball?
我闻到了披萨味。我知道我在这边。另一个不好的练习是抢球。学生们再次被分成两人一组。其中一人得到一个球。另一人被告知他有30秒的时间去把球抢过来。学生们再次被分成两人一组。其中一人得到一个球。另一人被告知他有30秒的时间去把球抢过来。几乎每次第二个学生都会试图把球抢夺过来。时间到后，辅导员会问：你有没有想过可能还有更简单的方法？比如直接开口要球呢？
On one level these exercises seem almost hokey. They're teaching age-old lessons. Trust your friends, look out for each other, think before acting. But these are lessons we all forget. We all need reminding, especially maybe if we happen to be 17, to slow down. The BAM program tries hard not to be preachy and tell the young men what to do. It's mostly trying to show them that they have options. If we tell these kids you're never fight, that's just so unrealistic for the world in which they live. What we have to help them with is the idea, you know, you may have to fight sometimes. But what else you got in the toolkit and And which tool do you reach for first?
在某种程度上，这些练习看起来几乎有些老套。它们教导的是历久弥新的道理：信任你的朋友，守望相助，三思而后行。但这些都是我们所有人都会忘记的道理。我们需要有人提醒，特别是如果我们刚好17岁的话，需要放慢节奏。BAM项目极力避免采用说教的方式去告诉年轻人该怎么做。它主要是向他们展示他们其实有多种选择。如果我们告诉这些孩子们“绝对不能打架”，这对于他们所生活的世界来说太不切实际了。我们必须帮助他们建立这样的观念：你知道的，有时你可能不得不打架。但你的工具箱里还有什么别的？你首先会伸手去拿哪个工具？
How it lays out a dilemma that a young man at or might face? Well, if you're a 17-year-old kid and you have a really nice jacket and you're walking home from school with it, you can't be the kind of kid that other kids think they can just come and take your jacket. You have to be tough. And so there's a very practical need that they have to deter the predations of other people around them. How do you avoid fights without communicating weakness? One of the students in the BAM program
奥尔高中的一个年轻人可能会面临怎样的两难境地呢？好吧，如果你是一个17岁的孩子，你有一件非常漂亮的夹克，你穿着它放学回家，你不能成为那种让别的孩子觉得随随便便就能过来把你的夹克抢走的孩子。你必须表现得强硬。因此，他们有一种非常现实的需求，那就是去遏制周围其他人对他们的掠夺。如何在不表现出软弱的情况下避免打架？BAM项目的一名学生
says he faces this dilemma all the time. I'm not in control, physically I'm happy, but the tense, pons waiting, you know, because I'm already old. Can Tron and I stepped outside so he could tell me his story. He's been in and out of trouble. For a while he was sent to a residential behavioral health program to help him get his anger on the control. Even there, Cantrell says, he sometimes lost it.
说他一直面临着这种两难境地。我无法控制自己，身体上我是开心的，但在紧张的期待中，你知道的，因为我已经老了。康特隆和我走到外面，好让他把他的故事告诉我。他一直麻烦不断。有一段时间，他被送到一个寄宿制行为健康项目，以帮助他控制愤怒。即使在那里，康特隆说，他有时还是会失控。
I had a roommate and he was like, he was real nice. He used to pee on the toilet seat and they want to clean it off so I guess he had angered too and then I told him by the sub and then he kept doing it so then we used to argue fighting not just blank out and just start fighting and stuff like that and then every time that happens I end up thinking about the consequences. Cantrell strikes me as a curious mixture of toughness and vulnerability. He slender and stares at the ground a lot, but there is a coil inside him. That coil can unspring in an instant.
我有一个室友，他人挺好的。他经常在马桶圈上小便，而且从不清理干净，所以我想他也有脾气，然后我跟他提过这事但他还是继续这样做，于是我们就会争吵、打架，不是那种直接断片然后开始打架之类的，然后每次发生这种情况，我最后都会去想后果。康特隆给我留下的印象是强硬与脆弱的奇妙结合。他身材苗条，总是盯着地面发呆，但他内心的深处盘踞着一根弹簧。这根弹簧随时可能会瞬间弹出。
Like the time some kids try to steal his jacket outside school. To Cantrell, it was more than just about the jacket. It was a sign of disrespect. The other kids were saying, you're a punk, we can push you around. To me, like as a man, all I...it's not a good thing to say, but I look at myself like a man
就像有一次几个孩子在学校外面试图偷他的夹克。对康特隆来说，这不仅仅是一件夹克的事。这是一个不被尊重的信号。其他孩子在说，你是个懦夫，我们可以对你为所欲为。对我来说，作为一个男人，我所有的……这不是什么好话，但我把自己看作一个男人，
as my prideful and myself, and I feel like they downgraded my pride and they respected me. When they did that to me, and they heard my pride real bad, and to like, give, like, earned my pride back, and feel back honored, I want to teach them a lesson. Cantral Smolder all night about the incident. The next day at school, he attacked a student,
我有我的自尊和自我，我觉得他们贬低了我的自尊，不尊重我。当他们对我这样做，并且严重伤害了我的自尊时，为了找回我的自尊，重新找回尊严，我想给他们一个教训。康特隆为这起事件生了一整晚闷气。第二天在学校里，他袭击了一个学生，
he thought was part of the group that had jumped him. And I was mad, so I just ran into him, hit him in his face like I had him in these like three times, and I had buses look. It turned out, Cantrell got it wrong. The student he attacked hadn't been involved. He realized this was the kind of behavior he needed to change. He needed to make better decisions, to slow down, to think. Cantrell told me his anger surged when he recently saw a guy talking to his girlfriend.
他以为那个学生是围攻他的人群中的一员。我很生气，所以我直接冲过去，照着他的脸打过去，我像这样揍了他三四下，然后巡视人员就来了。事实证明，康特隆搞错了。他袭击的那个学生根本没有参与其中。他意识到这就是他需要改变的行为。他需要做出更好的决定，放慢速度，进行思考。康特隆告诉我，当他最近看到一个家伙在跟他的女朋友说话时，他的怒火一下子就涌上来了。
Again, he saw it as disrespect. In his mind, the other student was saying, you aren't man enough to keep your girl. But instead of punching the other student as he had wanted to do, Cantrell went up and talked to him. The other student said he had no interest do, Cantrell went up and talked to him. The other student said he had no interest in Cantrell's girlfriend. They were just chatting. That was it. All of a sudden, something that could have ended in blows ended with a nod.
同样，他认为这是不尊重。在他脑海里，那个学生在说，你连自己的女友都保护不好，根本算不上个真正的男人。但康特隆并没有像以前那样想去痛扁那个学生，而是走过去和他谈了谈。那个学生说他对康特隆的女友根本没有兴趣。他们只是在闲聊。事情就是这样。突然之间，一场本可能以拳脚相向收场的事情，以一个点头致意结束了。
When I say goodbye to Cantrell, I feel uneasy. I have the sense he's on a knife edge. I can see him graduating and doing well in a couple of years, but I can also see him getting into trouble. And that brings us back to Jens Ludwig and Harold Pollack, the researchers who were studying the effectiveness of the BAM program. What they found precisely mirrors what I saw in Cantrell. Does BAM work? Will it keep young men like Cantrell out of jail? Well, the answer
当我向康特隆告别时，我感到有些不安。我有一种他正走在刀刃上的感觉。我能看到他在几年后顺利毕业并过得很好，但我也能看到他惹上麻烦。这就把我们带回了延斯·勒德威格和哈罗德·波拉克，这两位研究BAM项目有效性的研究人员。他们的发现完全反映了我在康特隆身上看到的情况。BAM管用吗？它能让像康特隆这样的年轻人远离监狱吗？嗯，答案是
is yes and no. Let's start with the good news. Remember the idea of controlling automatic behavior? Well, it says Harold, that works. When kids are participating in BAM, they're responding less automatically to dangerous situations. In fact, the results of the control study of BAM showed that it worked jaw-droppingly well. While students were in BAM, arrest rates plummeted by 44%. Here's Yens. I fell off my chair when I saw the initial set of results, indicating that the arrest rates for kids in the becoming a man program were 44% lower than the non-participants. These are massive reductions in violent crime arrest rates. Yens calls the results
既是也不是。让我们从好消息说起。还记得控制自动化行为的想法吗？嗯，哈罗德说，这管用。当孩子们参与BAM项目时，他们在面对危险情境时表现出的自动化反应减少了。事实上，BAM对照研究的结果表明，它的效果好得令人瞠目结舌。在参与BAM期间，学生的逮捕率骤降了44%。这是延斯。当我看到最初的一组结果时，我差点从椅子上摔下来。这表明参加“成为一个男人”项目的孩子们的逮捕率比未参与者低44%。这是暴力犯罪逮捕率的大幅下降。延斯称这些结果
stunning, almost miraculous. And there was more good news. Bam even seemed to help with school. Kids were more likely to come to school. They were more likely to be enrolled at the end of the school year. There's less likely to have dropped out. And they are less likely to fail their classes. Yens and Harold can now say with certainty that the Bam program works. It's a huge success for young men without many good options.
令人震惊，简直近乎奇迹。而且还有更多好消息。BAM甚至似乎对学校教育有帮助。孩子们更有可能来上学。他们更有可能在学年结束时保持学籍。他们辍学的可能性更小。他们挂科的可能性也更小。延斯和哈罗德现在可以肯定地说，BAM项目确实有效。对于缺乏优质选择的年轻男子来说，这是一个巨大的成功。
But sadly, there is a catch. The reduction in violence doesn't stick once young men lack control are done with school and done with BAM. They are offending at the same rates as the control group after the program is over. So if I look at their arrest rates in the year after they're done with the program, and I compare their arrest rates with kids in the control group in the same year after the program is over, I really don't see differences there. Harold and Yens don't
但遗憾的是，这里有个问题。一旦这些控制力不足的年轻男子完成了学业并结束了BAM项目，暴力行为的减少就无法持续了。项目结束后，他们再次犯罪的比率与对照组持平。因此，如果我查看他们在完成项目后那一年的逮捕率，并将他们的逮捕率与对照组在项目结束后的同一年里的逮捕率进行比较，我真的看不出两者的差异。哈罗德和延斯并不
know why what's taught in BAM doesn't last once the program ends, but it actually makes sense. All of us need reminders of advice we've gotten many times in the past. Take a breath, look at things in perspective, talk to a friend if you're feeling down. Yen says it's hard to change behavior, especially for kids who've led traumatic lives. But he still feels the program offers more reason to be optimistic than pessimistic. I'm an economist by training and the way that I think about whether a social program is worth doing or not is I think about what the program costs and then I think about what it does to help kids and society as a whole.
知道为什么BAM中教导的内容在项目结束后就无法持续，但这其实合情合理。我们所有人都需要有人提醒我们过去多次听过的建议：深呼吸，客观地看待事物，如果感到沮丧就找朋友倾诉。延斯说，改变行为很难，尤其是对那些经历过创伤生活的孩子来说。但他仍然觉得，这个项目带给人的乐观理由多于悲观理由。我受过经济学训练，我思考一个社会项目是否值得去做的方式是，我先考虑这个项目的成本，然后考虑它对帮助孩子和整个社会所起的作用。
And whether the value of the social impact is enough to justify the program cost. And a 44% reduction in violence involvement for at-risk kids for one year generates benefits to society that easily outweigh the program costs. So we've estimated that the benefit cost ratio might be as high as 31 for this inter-rengeon. And there are tangible benefits to the young men who stay crime free, even if it's just for a year. If I have a year where I have fewer offenses, then even if I commit offenses after that,
以及社会影响的价值是否足以证明项目成本是合理的。对于高风险儿童而言，暴力卷入率降低44%持续一年，给社会带来的效益轻易就能超过项目成本。因此我们估计，针对这项干预措施，其效益成本比最高可达31比1。对于那些远离犯罪的年轻人来说，即使只有一年，也有切实的好处。如果我有那么一年犯罪次数减少了，那么即使我在那之后犯罪，
it's still, you know, it's accumulating into a less destructive record for me if people are talking about does this person need to be held in a secure facility or something like that? Of course, when you've met young men like Cantrell on the knife edge, you want more for them. A less destructive criminal record isn't enough. These scenes haven't failed in any irreparable way, as yet. I see it like this. A scientific study has found that you can build a new kind of bridge, one that is good and strong. It could take these young men to a successful adulthood. But that bridge is only halfway done. At the end of every BAM session at Oroh High School, the students have to check out,
它积攒下来的犯罪记录对我的破坏性仍然会小一些，如果人们在讨论这个人是否需要被关进安全设施或者类似的地方时的话。当然，当你遇到像康特隆这样处在刀刃上的年轻人时，你会对他们抱有更多期望。一个破坏性较小的犯罪记录是不够的。这些年轻人还没有以任何无可挽回的方式失败。我是这样看的。一项科学研究发现，你可以建造一种新型桥梁，一座既好又坚固的桥梁。它能够将这些年轻人带向一个成功的成年期。但那座桥只建了一半。在奥尔高中每节BAM课程结束时，学生们都必须进行签退，
to say one word that is on their minds. When I hear those words, I want that bridge completed. Faith, and with that I'm out. Session, with that I'm out. Excited, excellent. Fantastic, you can come out. Love, and with that I'm out. I love it. Thank you.
说出一个萦绕在他们心头的词。当我听到那些词时，我多么希望那座桥能最终建成。信念，这就是我的心声。结束，这就是我的心声。兴奋，太棒了。好极了，你可以出来了。爱，这就是我的心声。我太喜欢了。谢谢。
Thank you. You know what I mean? Let it go. You know what I mean? You know what I mean? I'll tell you what I mean. This week's show was produced by Jenny Schmidt and edited by Tara Boyer. Our staff includes Rainer Cohen, Laura Correll, Parts Shah and Thomas Liu.
谢谢。你明白我的意思吗？放手吧。你明白我的意思吗？你明白我的意思吗？我告诉你我是什么意思。本周的节目由珍妮·施密特制作，塔拉·博耶剪辑。我们的团队成员包括雷纳·科恩、劳拉·科雷尔、帕茨·沙阿和托马斯·刘。
We had original music this week from Romteen Arableui. Our run song hero today is Alpha Drabo. Alpha was an IT specialist at NPR until not long ago, and he was a voice of reassurance when our computers, inexplicably, behave like computers. Thank you, Alpha, for sharing your tech savvy and your kindness. For more Hidden Brain, you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter. If you liked this episode, please tell one friend who doesn't know about Hidden Brain about our show.
本周的原创音乐来自龙坦·阿拉布鲁伊。我们今天的跑腿英雄是阿尔法·德拉博。阿尔法不久前还是NPR的IT专家，每当我们的计算机莫名其妙地表现得像计算机时，他就是那个带来安抚声音的人。谢谢你，阿尔法，感谢你分享你的技术专长和善良。想了解更多《隐藏的大脑》的内容，你可以在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们。如果你喜欢这期节目，请把我们的节目推荐给一位还不知道《隐藏的大脑》的朋友。
Tell us on social media whom you've tapped. I'm Shankar Vedantum, and this is NPR. Hey, trust in our mouth. Happy with that amount. Awesome. And with that amount. That's very funny. Really, guys, we got so many.
在社交媒体上告诉我们你向谁推荐了。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆，这是NPR。嘿，相信我们。对那个金额很满意。太棒了。还有那个金额。这太搞笑了。真的，伙计们，我们有这么多。
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。
Thank you. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢。谢谢。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。